- Woo!
KFC and Wendy's need to get together.
You guys--
- [Man] Sign a treaty.
- Make a baby.
Live and direct from Hollywood,
- It's your girl Freddie.
- It's your boy,
(record scratch)
Freddie made me say that but I can't.
- We're going to go to
one fast food restaurant.
- Get our favorite food from there.
- And then we're going to go to
another fast food restaurant.
- Find a food that best compliments
that food that we chose before.
- Weld them together,
and make a masterpiece.
- How are we going to choose
these fast food restaurants?
This bad boy.
Mad restaurants on the wheel.
We're going to spin them,
- And choose whatever lands first.
It looks like we're going to Maydonalds.
- One more thing,
we need our lab here.
- Swagged out.
- Let's go to McDonald's.
- Let's go. Okay.
- [Steven] You like chicken nuggets.
- Yes, I'm into chicken nuggets.
- I love chicken nuggets.
- What kind of sauce?
- Buffalo. What do you like?
- I usually get ranch or BBQ.
We got it!
- 50 McNuggets.
Spin the wheel, and stop.
Chipotle.
- Chicken McPotle.
- [Freddie] Lets do this!
- [Steven] Lets do it!
- All right. Let's go!
- What do you like from Chipotle?
- I don't know, well
we gotta find something
that complements the McNuggets.
- Okay, what's (laughs)
- What makes the mashup good?
- Is that a word?
- Does it look cool?
- Does it look fly?
- Fly
- Like Freddie.
- And taste.
- Now we're gonna try this.
Let's do this.
All right, rice first.
- Rice and beans, yeah.
Cuz that comes before the meat.
Place the Chicken McNuggets inside.
- Are we gonna dice them up nicely,
or are we just gonna throw them in there?
We gotta be classy.
- [Steven] No.
- [Freddie] We're gonna put
a little bit of ranch in here.
- [Steven] Double sauce?
- [Freddie] Yeah.
- [Steven] Alright.
Double sauce?
- Should we double team?
- And there you have it.
The Chicken McNugget Chipotle Burrito.
Cheers.
- (laughs) Cheers.
I think it's outstanding.
- You know what I do like about this?
Is the ranch and buffalo sauce.
It provides a new element
that I've never had in Chipotle burrito.
- Rubric.
Six out of 10 on originality,
Complementar-ianism? I think is on point.
- 10.
- I mean who would've
thought to put guac, buffalo
sauce, and ranch together?
Aesthetics. The food
baby looked impeccable.
Taste was an eight.
- 30/40 is the final score.
That was pretty good.
So we're going to go to our next place.
Ask the Wheel of Steddie.
- Wendy's.
- All right so we're pulling
up on Wendy's right now,
and we're gonna find our
favorite Wendy's item.
What do you like?
(laughs) I was thinking the same thing!
- I'm so nervous, if we
end up at Panda Express
and I have to eat, put a
piece of orange chicken
in this Frostie, Imma be pissed.
- Thank you so much.
What do you say when
something tastes really good?
- I say Flames.
I brought Flames back.
- [Steven] Flames?
- Figure out where we going next Steven.
- All right so we're goin'
Mr. KFC, Colonel Sanders.
That sounds delicious!
- Sounds amazing.
- Fried chicken?
- Biscuits!
- Biscuit you know that biscuit.
- We're gonna dip the biscuit
in the Frostie.
- We got the Frostie.
- We got the biscuits.
- Let's get to work.
Feast Mode
- [Freddie] Hunger Squad.
- [Steven] Let's go.
- [Freddie] Woo!
- [Steven] Cheers.
- [Freddie] Cheers.
- [Steven] Dip. Woo!
- [Freddie] Woo boy!
- Whoa!
- Hold up, hold up, hold up.
- That is so good!
- The biscuits are the perfect texture
This though, Flames.
I just think we should
call it Colonel Wendy.
- All right, rubric.
It's pretty original.
- This might kind of
give chicken and waffles
a run for its money.
- Complementar-ianism? Off the charts.
Aesthetic? As you dip it and you get,
like that coming off, it looks so good.
- Taste?
- Perfect. Perfect 10.
Alright so total score we got 39.
- Ok that's literally--
- Almost perfect.
Masterpiece.
- It's pretty good actually.
- We've done it.
- [Freddie] Woo!
- Spin the wheel!
- Next spot.
- Subway!
- [Freddie] Subway, subway, subway.
- Eat fresh!
(sigh) Getting a little bit sick actually.
- I usually get the
Italian sub with salami,
and cold cuts.
- [Steven] Cold cuts!
I'm all about that cold cut.
- So Steven's in the car
'cause there's no parking
so I'm gonna go do the dirty work.
Think I'm gonna get the spicy italian
with pickles.
Let's go!
Got the goods!
- A spin of the wheel.
What do we got?
Taco Bell!
- [Freddie] Taco Bell!
You know what I really like?
Crunchwrap Supreme.
What are we gonna name this baby?
- The last hurrah.
- We'll go back to the
office to put this together.
- Back at Buzzfeed headquarters,
What are we making here?
We have a Crunchwrap Supreme,
- And we have an Italian sub.
Let's go. Get dirty.
- Italian sub.
- [Steven] Woo! That's strong.
- [Freddie] What kind of meat's on it?
- [Steven] And then we got
the Crunchwrap Supreme.
- I think we should just
put this whole thing in.
- Whoa!
- Why'd you take your glasses off?
- Oh!
I'll take a bite from this end,
you take a bite from that end.
- Not at the same time.
- I know that Freddie.
- This is not Steven (laughs)
Is it a range of emotion?
(laughs) Too much bread and dough.
I don't even taste the flavor.
- Mm. Still pretty good.
I feel like it's one of
those things where I'm like,
No, no, no, ok.
Rubric.
Originality?
- Super super duper original.
- Nobody would ever do this.
- Yeah. Complementar-ianism.
I just wanted more crunchwrap.
I think this looks pretty (bleep) awesome.
Alright, and then,
- [Steven] Taste.
- [Freddie] Taste.
I give it a three.
I'm sad, you know, I thought
we were gonna end on a bang,
this was supposed to be the last hurrah.
How do you think today went?
Ol' Stevie, ol' pal.
We went to six places in
- Three hours.
The biscuits was probably--
- The biscuits with the
Frostie was my favorite too.
- I feel like a mad genius.
- Okay. So until next time?
- What do you want us to do next?
It's your boy Steven signing out.
- (laughs) God.